is from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to low in crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber Alec Murdock faced more
grueling questioning on Friday as the
state wraps up its cross-examination of
the former attorney accused of killing
his wife Maggie and Son Paul all eyes
were once again on Murdoch as he and
Lead prosecutor Creighton Waters faced
off Waters played multiple clips from
Murdoch's first interview with sled
agents just after he discovered the
bodies of his wife and son and we now
know that Murdoch lied to the
investigators saying that he was asleep
on the couch and never came down to the
kennels where Maggie and Paul were
gunned down
at what point did you decide to lie I'm
not sure but it was in that it was in
this interview I believe that it was
okay was this interview where you're
sitting in the front seat correct it is
you're not in custody correct I'm not in
custody they're giving you water letting
you chew tobacco treating you politely
correct who treated me very politely so
what was it that the click when so you
said in this interview that it collected
I that I'm gonna lie about the most
important fact that I know I'm not sure
exactly when in it that I I decided to
lie but I believe it was during this
interview don't talk to anybody without
a lawyer uh Partners all told me that or
a lot of my partners told me that my
different
Chief Alexander was one that said that I
overheard I believe it was Sheriff Hill
I'm not positive I overheard him tell I
believe Mark baller gray homes don't let
him talk to anybody without a lawyer and
what I believe is that
based on my distrust of sled
and getting in that interview and I'm
not positive about this but I believe
when he asked me you know about my
relationship with my wife and my son I
believe that's when I decided to lie I
believe those guys were trying to help
me I believe they cared about me I
believe they thought that I was in a
condition such that I shouldn't
talk to anybody
um I mean
I mean those guys had to prop Me Up
help me get myself together just to be
able to go talk to David Owens I mean
they were trying to help me but before
that that was just one of the many
things that
I believe led to that
situation sitting in there where those
paranoid thoughts came to me
during Thursday's testimony with his own
legal team Murdoch admitted to being at
his estate's kennels with Maggie and
Paul who he sometimes referred to as
pawpaw now multiple Witnesses identified
Murdoch's voice on a video that Paul
took just before the murders despite
Murdoch telling investigators multiple
times in multiple interviews that he
didn't go down to the kennels on June
7th now the prosecutor wanted to know
why Murdoch didn't come clean any time
before he was put on the stand
before yesterday
did you ever bring up what you told the
story about that Kennels to anybody in
the prosecution or anybody in law
enforcement
no I didn't have the opportunity to Mr
Waters because you
would not respond to my invitations to
reach out and tell you about all the
things that I done wrong
and to talk about bringing this to a
head to talk about bringing this
conclusion I understand how many people
I hurt I understand
um how angry my partners are and how
hurt they are and I understand how hurt
these people that I stole money
from art I understand how hurt they are
and one of the things that I believe is
getting past this may help them get some
closure and so since at least January
I've been trying to sit down with y'all
to talk to y'all okay and never
never
got a response to the multiple requests
multiple requests yes sir multiple
requests
all right time to break it down join my
co-host legal analyst defense attorney
Brian buckmeyer former trial Attorney
Terry Austin it's good to have you both
here Terry I'll start with you Murdoch
gave multiple excuses for lying about
his whereabouts do you think the jury
believes those excuses I don't think so
I mean he keeps changing the story first
he said he was paranoid because of the
opioids okay then he said when he was
doing that interview at first he wasn't
going to lie but then he decided he
wanted to lie because they were asking
him questions about his wife and his son
and the relationship not good and then
he said he distrusted sled why why does
he distrust them he's a police officer
or he's a former officer of the court
and so he should not be distrusting
these people you know and then basically
he just said he didn't think it would
promote the investigation of the case
well of course it would then he said his
law Partners you know advised him not to
say anything the bottom line is he is
guilty and this is consciousness of
guilt and this is why he lied well that
Terry's point of view Brian I go to you
you didn't think we spoke about this you
didn't think the cross-examination by
Creighton Waters was that good right I
think it was horrible really I think
when it comes to cross-examination you
got one or two things either you're
going to lock them in with yes or no
questions and you're really gonna box
him into showing that hey this guy is
not just a liar because it's clear he's
a liar but he murdered his wife and son
the other thing I was giving him the
benefit of the doubt until he finished
his cross-examination and Terry actually
gave me this analogy that I thought this
was going to be like giving him Rope
Rope Rope Rope Rope till he hangs
himself like we saw in the Robert Durst
case with the cross-examination where
the prosecutors gave him all the rope in
the world and then came back and slammed
over their head with his own words but
it looked like Alex Murdoch was kind of
dancing through between raindrops I know
he's a liar but I'm not convinced that
he's actually a murderer okay see this
is still up for debate this is why I
think there's going to be a hung jury
and I'll tell you what long crime the
long crime network is your home for
gavel to gavel coverage of the Alec
Murdoch trial you can watch live streams
from inside the courtroom here at expert
Insight from legal professionals like
Terry Ryan and you can see information
like timelines exhibits it's all on
lawncrime.com and every day here on
lawncrime Dot and long crime daily we're
going to be right back with more
coverage of Alec Murdoch's testimony
[Music]
and welcome back everybody so we're back
now with continuing coverage of Alec
Murdoch's testimony in his double murder
trial you see Murdoch decided to take
the stand on Thursday and he admitted
during direct examination that he had an
opioid addiction for around 20 years
that he had been stealing from his law
firm and clients for at least a decade
and that he had lied to just about
everyone but he adamantly denied having
anything to do with Maggie and Paul's
murders when Creighton Waters began
cross-examination he hammered Murdoch
about the money that he stole from his
clients people who were vulnerable after
life-changing accidents who needed the
money coming to them in settlements
Murdoch and Waters sparred several times
over everything from Facts to semantics
but you can't tell us one time where it
just sticks out of your memory where
you're like
I'm pulling the fast one right now oh no
or anything whatever reaction you had no
no a single one no sir that's not
correct I can remember a lot of times
where
I lied to my clients I misled my clients
and I stole money from my clients in
conversations
but for me to sit and tell you that I
had a conversation about this particular
document I don't dispute it
I know you don't dispute it Mr Martin
you've said that a hundred times haven't
you
but you can't recall for this jury one
of these people looking them in the eye
while you lie to them you can't recall a
single one I've asked you this three
times now oh I promise you the honor
asked and answered three times
here here you go Mr Waters
the points me isn't it Mr Murdock
I I I don't know if you points made or
not but here here's here's you don't
know that either here's what I will say
again
I remember lying
to clients of mine
I did it on
more than one occasion
I took their money when I shouldn't have
taken it I'm sure that I looked them in
the eye I'm sure that I misled them
but I can't tell you exactly when those
occurred 12 years ago is the only point
I don't dispute that day occurred
I don't dispute that everything about
what I did was wrong
okay but I can't sit and tell you the
specific details that you're wanting me
to give you
[Music]
it's safe to say that there is a long
weekend ahead as the country Ponders two
days of testimony from Alec Murdock and
while we can't read the minds of the
jurors in the courtroom we have the
second best thing and that is the court
of public opinion so we set up a poll on
our YouTube live stream and here's what
you our viewers have to say 66 percent
of you believe that Murdoch is guilty 11
of you say he's not guilty 15 percent
think that there's going to be a hung
jury and seven percent are still
undecided now we do have some time
before the jury has to make that
decision but our boots on the ground
have a clear shot of that jury box so
let's listen in his long crimes very own
Gigi McKelvey in South Carolina attorney
Joe McCullough share their observations
from inside the courtroom as Murdoch
took the stand for the second day
it's hard to tell I mean for the most
part it's very much poker face and but
you do see these little subtle things I
mean for instance yesterday A lot of
people have been talking about that
passing of the tissue I mean is that
just kind of like an instinct to do it
or was it hey man you're sobbing I feel
bad for you here's a tissue it's hard to
tell if they're buying it or not you see
frustration kind of come in waves across
that jury depending on the line of
questioning but as far as what they're
thinking man I I wish I could hop in
their brains for a hot second for sure
well I think that the jury is going to
take into account and they'll certainly
be reminded by the defense and closings
this is a fella Who Came Upon a family
Slaughter and he was not asked by the
investigator tell me in chronological
order in perfect order what you did when
you did it and exactly what you said
that's not the way things happen police
officers matter of fact when they're
involved in the shooting they get a 24
High 24-hour Hiatus before their
interview about the shooting to give
them time to collect their thoughts so
kind of a different standard for
Witnesses or victims in crimes people
who come upon things so I think the
jury's not going to give much Credence
to that quote unquote problem
but I think what's happening in there
now about when the big lie got invented
and tightening this timeline and
challenging military
that's that's going to help the
prosecution
Terry we're coming to the end of the
case one thing we haven't talked about
is the performance of the judge how do
you think judge Newman performed during
the course of this case he's one of my
favorite judges he's been on the bench
since 2000 he'll be on the bench till 27
because he's been re-elected he runs a
very tight Court he's done a lot of high
profile cases one of them was the Walter
Scott case which you might recall he was
shot in the back he was stopped for a
broken brake light and this case I think
he's running a tight ship one thing you
know about Judge Newman he is not going
to make any sort of preemptory decision
he wants to see the evidence he wants to
hear the questions then he'll make a
learn it decision the other thing is he
knows the case law so he makes this
decision based on what the law is and I
really like that and he has developed a
great reputation so Brian you know what
I'm going to ask you you're seeing if
you were defense counsel here you see
the jury you're hearing your client
you're hearing the cross-examination how
would you be feeling right now I'm
feeling good I know you put up those
numbers in that chart there Jesse but
for the four different categories but in
my mind I see two two things I see
two-thirds of people who have watched
this trial like a hawk and a lot more
information that the jury probably
hasn't heard and they say guilty and
everyone else a third is saying not
guilty at this point I think the defense
only has to get up there and strongly
explain this is not about innocent or
guilty this is about whether or not the
prosecution has proven this case Beyond
a reasonable doubt you you explain that
Reasonable Doubt thoroughly to them and
I think this is a hung jury I can't see
a guilty verdict through all this
confusion I think they've got a good
case I I think a hungry I don't
anticipate in acquittal across the board
but I've been wrong before we will wait
and see Brian Terry thank you both so
much everyone thanks for joining us here
on Long crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
foreign
[Music]